und die neu gewählte spd
bundestagsfraktion kommt heute morgen
zusammen um ihre spitze neu zu wählen
und mein kollege erhard scherfer ist für
uns dabei in berlin er hat die spd ist
der wahlgewinner
die fraktion deshalb so groß wie lange
nicht mehr und jetzt anders als vor vier
jahren ausgesprochen regierungswillig
wie beobachten die sozialdemokraten denn
die gespräche zwischen den grünen und
der fdp also die vor sondierungen
das ist eine ziemlich gute und auch
außerdem sehr berechtigte frage seiner
bilder denn wir haben in den vergangenen
tagen ja schon gesehen wie man ja ich
sag mal so ein bisschen flapsig daher
bei der spd mit den hufen gescharrt wird
man will tatsächlich anders als vor vier
jahren diesmal wirklich ran und diesmal
ist die begeisterung etwas an der
regierung zu gestalten doch tatsächlich
auch mal da und der denke ich ist es am
besten wir fragen danach wo man das am
besten weiß nämlich in der fraktion und
deswegen freue ich mich dass einer der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
bei uns ist nämlich dirk wiese herzlich
willkommen und guten morgen ihnen ja
widmen jetzt müssen sie noch eine weile
zu gucken obwohl sie ja eigentlich
machen wollen anders als vor vier jahren
haben jetzt gerade gesagt wie ist das
wenn man da erstmal zuschauen muss
das noch nicht ganz 72 stunden her dass
die bürgerinnen und bürger eine
entscheidung getroffen haben wir freuen
uns immer noch sehr über diese
entscheidung olaf scholz ist der klare
wahlsieger des abends wir leiten daraus
auch ein anspruch auf diese regierung zu
führen eine kommende regierung zu führen
dass olaf scholz der nächste kanzler
wird aber ich kann ihnen sagen die
stimmung bei uns in der fraktion ist
sehr gut wir haben viele neue gesichter
wir freuen uns und wir wollen jetzt mit
ruhe und gelassenheit die kommenden tage
angeht das ist so ein bisschen teilhaben
es gab ja gestern die erste
fraktionssitzung mit den bisherigen
abgeordneten aber auch schon mit der
neuen abends gab es dann die
die party sag ich mal bei seeheimer
kreis wobei bei beiden veranstaltungen
auch olaf scholz dabei gewesen ist wie
es abgelaufen sehr gut die stimmung ist
gut das wird man auch nachvollziehen
können wir haben auch viele neue
gesichter in der spd-bundestagsfraktion
auch viele junge gesichter das sind ganz
tolle biographien die viel
unterschiedlichkeit auch mit in diese
fraktion hineinbringen aber die stimmung
war gelöst und alle freuen sich einfach
über diesen schlussspurt der gemeinsam
mit olaf scholz dazu geführt hat dass
wir stärkste fraktion im deutschen
bundestag sind aber die erwartungen dann
tatsächlich auch an die regierung zu
kommen die sind doch groß oder täusch
ich mich selbstverständlich wir leiten
daraus auch den klaren auftrag gehabt
die kommende bundesregierung zu führen
mit olaf scholz als kanzler wir wollen
jetzt mit ruhe und gelassenheit die
kommenden tage auch angehen gespräche
suchen langsam voran gehen und wie
gesagt heute auch die ersten
weichenstellungen in der fraktion
vornehmen welche weichenstellungen genau
wir werden heute rolf mützenich im amt
des fraktionsvorsitzenden bestätigen
rolf mützenich hat viel dazu beigetragen
dass diese fraktion ein stabilitätsanker
auch in der letzten regierung gewesen
ist dass die fraktion mit redet dass die
fraktionen auch ein selbstbewusstsein
hat sicherlich auch noch schwierigen
zeiten die wir in der bundestagsfraktion
gehabt haben und darum betroffen wenn
ich heute mit einem klaren und
eindeutigen signalen ausgestattet werden
und dabei bleibt erstmal die
stellvertreterposten die position die
werden dann erst mal einer der folgenden
sitzung gewählt werden nämlich an die
anderen fraktionen machen sehr ähnlich
genau das ist durchaus üblich dass die
jeweiligen gegen ihren funktionen sind
kommissarisch im amt bleiben aber es ist
natürlich auch wichtig den
fraktionsvorsitzenden und einem starken
signal aus zustand mit einem klaren
signal anders als er sicherlich gestern
bei der cdu gewesen ist jetzt sagen sie
klarer wählerauftrag für die spd
gleichwohl muss es doch merkwürdig sein
werden ausgerechnet die kleineren aber
jetzt nicht mehr ganz so kleinen partner
jetzt erst mal untereinander ausmachen
wo sie ihre gemeinsamkeiten sehen und wo
man ja auch noch nicht weiß so wirklich
in welche richtung das dann gehen wir
hat ob sie sich möglicherweise doch
erstmal einrichtung union wenden um die
gespräche zu führen oder doch erst mal
mit der spd sprechen wollen das ist ja
selbstverständlich dass gespräche
gesucht werden und wenn man eins an
diesem wahlabend zusammenfasst dann ist
es dass wir drei wahlsiege haben das ist
die spd das sind die grünen und das sind
die fdp die stimmenzuwächse erzielt
haben und wir haben einen klaren
wahlverlierers armin laschet und wenn
ich mir sehe dass viele bundesbürger
sagen dass er die niederlage anerkennen
soll was vielleicht bei ihm noch nicht
so gereift ist dann leitet sich daraus
bei mir jedenfalls weg der anspruch bei
uns ab wir haben diesen
regierungsauftrag wir wollen die
gespräche suchen und es gibt gerade auch
mit grünen und fdp in den
unterschiedlichsten politikfeldern viele
schnittmengen die einfach auch da sind
dass man dieses land zukunftsfähig
machen will dass man fortschritt
gestalten will und dass man eine
progressive regierung voranbringen sie
haben es angedeutet armin laschet hat
das mit der wahlniederlage ist noch
nicht so richtig
akzeptiert hat man den eindruck er
leitet angebote aus dem ergebnis ab bei
der abstand zwischen union und spd nicht
besonders groß ist was ja tatsächlich
dann auch stimmt jenseits von den
prozentpunkten die ja dann die union
auch tatsächlich verloren hatte und
jetzt versucht man trotzdem noch mal mit
grünen und fdp ins gespräch zu kommen
wenn sie sich das alles ansehen wie
wirkt das auf sie das wirkt so ein
bisschen für mich dass armin laschet
versucht sich an den letzten strohhalm
zu klammern auch die gestrigen
entscheidung in der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion dass man
ralph brinkhaus für sieben monate wählt
das wir für mich wie ein unausgegorener
kompromiss letztendlich im hintergrund
scharren schon jetzt sparen friedrich
merz norbert röttgen mit den hufen das
sind alte
wunden die vielleicht auch wieder
aufbrechen durch die verlorene
vorsitzendenwahl bei dem ein oder
anderen also von daher das wirkt alles
sehr unsortiert bei mir markus söder hat
ja auch sag ich mal in nicht freundliche
art und weise schon erklärt dass sie
jetzt platz zwei an steht und damit eher
der gang in die opposition also das ist
schon ich würde ich sagen eine offene
feldschlacht die bei der union
stattfindet aber das ist schon ein
großes ein großer wir war der gestern
abend auch gewesen ist es wird hin und
wieder immer noch mal in die diskussion
geworfen geworfen wenn es möglicherweise
keine dreier konstellation gibt entweder
mit spd oder mit der union dass eine
große koalition unter führung der spd
auch nicht noch ganz ausgeschlossen ist
wie sehen sie das ich glaube dass es mit
grünen und fdp viele schnittmengen gibt
dieses land wirklich voranzubringen die
zukunftsausgaben aufgaben dieses landes
auch zu gestalten mehr zu investieren
eine fortschritts freundliche
bundesregierung auf den weg zu bringen
gerade auch gesellschaftspolitisch und
da sind wirklich die schnittmengen mit
fdp und grünen am größten wir gehen das
jetzt mit ruhe und gelassenheit an aber
dadurch die klare priorität sie haben
die themen angesprochen die für die spd
möglicherweise noch wichtig werden ihnen
oder überhaupt wichtig werden dieser
kommenden legislaturperiode
wir haben in den vergangenen
tagen auch immer wieder gehört dass da
vor allem der blick berichtet wird auf
die erhöhung des mindestlohnes da wird
auch beispielsweise der aspekt wohnen
immer mal wieder betont die
finanzpolitischen themen dokument so ein
bisschen aus offensichtlich
diplomatischen gründen nicht mehr ganz
so im vordergrund das natürlich auch im
vorfeld der gespräche zu tun hat was ist
für sie noch wichtig als fraktionsvize
der spd der sich um die bereiche recht
verbraucherschutz und innere sicherheit
in den vergangenen jahren gekümmert hat
ich glaube dass jede partei ihre
prioritäten in gespräche natürlich mit
einbringen wird das ist auch
selbstverständlich und ich glaube dass
es da sehr viele schnittmengen gibt wenn
man auch die programme über einander
nicht und gerade das kann ich sagen im
bereich der innen und rechtspolitik
glaube ich sind sehr viele schnittmengen
mit fdp und grünen auch erkennbar ich
kenne das noch aus der zeit mit cdu/csu
das war an vielen stellen sehr schwierig
aber verweigerungshaltung der war kein
modernes einwanderungsrecht erkennbar
dabei eine teilweise verstaubte
gesellschaftspolitik immer noch bei
union der cdu csu zu erkennen und von
daher auch gerade in diesem bereich gibt
es mit fdp und den grünen sehr viele
schnittmengen die dazu führen können
dass man hier erfolgreiche verhandlungen
führen kann ganz interessanter punkt den
sie die ansprechende michael theurer
heute morgen im deutschlandfunk gehört
der im zusammenhang mit der
einwanderungspolitik tatsächlich den
beruf spurwechsel verwendet hat der ja
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere
tatsächlich aus der spd fraktion kommt
ist allerdings schon vor ein paar jahren
mal diskutiert worden wie sieht es dann
aus mitmachen das vielleicht ein
bisschen konkreter mit den punkten wie
wie sie angedeutet haben als
schnittmengen und die in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode nicht realisierbar
waren die aber möglicherweise mit grünen
und fdp dann doch denkbar sind
beispielsweise was das wahlrecht angeht
wir haben jetzt sieben 135 abgeordnete
so viel wie noch nie da muss dringend
was passieren
wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass sie dann
indiana colts dreier konstellation mit
grünen und fdp tatsächlich etwas bewegen
können wenn sie brauchen glaube ich dann
doch auch eine zwei drittel mehrheit
also erstmal glaube ich dass wir hier
mit fdp und grünen sehr schnell zu einem
vernünftigen ergebnis kommen können
gerade was diesem bereich anbelangt es
gab ja auch schon gute vorschläge von
fdp und grünen aus der vergangenen
legislaturperiode für zu sagen ja aber
es war immer letztendlich die cdu und
gerade die csu die gebremst hat die
immer wieder ihre vorteile ihre freunde
versucht hat auch beim wahlrecht zu
sichern sie haben immer wieder blockiert
um sozusagen mehrheiten auch abzusichern
zur benachteiligung auch der spd der fdp
und der grünen und von daher glaube ich
die schnittmengen auch hier sind mit fdp
und grünen sehr groß zu einem ergebnis
zu kommen der dazu führt das wahlrecht
auch anzupassen auch zu verändern aber
die blockierer kamen lange aus bayern an
federführung markus söder und alexander
dobrindt geben sie uns abschließend noch
ein anderes beispiel was sich bewegen
könnte oder schneller oder besser
bewegen könnte männer sollten in einer
solchen konstellation
wie sieht es beispielsweise mit dem
demokratie fördergesetz aus auch nicht
durchgekommen in der vergangenen
legislatur nein und das bedaure ich noch
sehr weil es eine einigung in der
bundesregierung gegeben hat selbst horst
seehofer hat hinter dem was wir
voranbringen wollten gestanden das war
nachher die cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
die ihren eigenen innenminister in den
rücken gefallen ist und das war sehr
bedauerlich ist wer wichtig dieses
demokratie fördergesetz zu haben und
auch hier sehe ich große schnittmengen
mit fdp und grünen zu einem wirklich
guten ergebnis zu kommen aber wir hätten
es auch haben können aber auch hier
waren cdu/csu die blockierer und von
daher wäre es richtig und wichtig dass
die sich jetzt mal in der opposition
erholen abschließend doch jetzt
endgültig abschließen was denken sie
wann wird es die ersten gespräche geben
zwischen spd und grünen und fdp ich bin
ein sklave
aller geduld die sie ja schon am anfang
dieses gesprächs immer wieder betont
haben ja ich bin ins gelingen verliebt
von daher wird das jetzt alles alles
wird letztendlich jetzt seinen gang
nehmen aber nochmal das ist gut jetzt
mit ruhe und gelassenheit an die sache
ranzugehen wir wollen es zum erfolg
führen wir wollen dass diese koalition
möglicherweise gelingt und wir wollen
dass olaf scholz kanzler wird und das
packen wir sagen und da würden sie
notfalls auch 14 tage warten
14 tage zwölf tage wir schauen einfach
mal am ende wie gesagt ins gelingen
verliebt wir wollen zum erfolg führen
wie so vielen dank